اكدت مجموعه من الباحثين فاعريا دواء جديد
لمرض الالفايمر بعد ما اكدت تجربه كلينكيه
انه يبطئ تدمير المرض للدماغ ويخفض
التدهور المعرفي لدى الماء المرضى الذين
يعانون من مراحل مبكره من المرض ووفقا
لشبكه بي بي سي البريطانيه فان هذا الدواء
الذي وصفه العلماء بالاختراق العلمي ينهي
عقودا من الفشل فيما يخص ابتكار علاجات
فعاله للالسايمر الدواء جديد الذي يدعى
بيلكوماب يهاجم بروتين بيتا اميولويد الذي
يتراكم في ادمغه الاشخاص المصابين بمرض
الالسايمر واجر الباحثون تجربه كلينيكيه
للدواء على الفن
1995 متطوعا يعانون من المرض في مراحله
المبكرا وتم اعطاء دفعات من الدواء الجديد
للمشاركين على مدار ثمانيه
10 شهرا ووجد الفريق في الدراسه التي نشرت
في مجله طبيه ان الدواء ابطا تدمير المرض
للدماغ بالنسبه 27% وقال عدد من خبراء
الصحه انه على الرغم من ان التاثير يعد
الى حد ما فانه يوفر املا كبيرا في
امكانيه علاج المرض بشكل الفعال في
المستقبل
[موسيقى]